islam will never be the same as red pill
and red pill will never be the same as
islam you look around and it's like oh
are you alpha uh no oh then by
definition you're beta are you red pill
no okay then you're blue pill or you're
an omega or a delta like bro what does
this even mean
like you're so caught up in like
arbitrary terminologies to label
yourself as in terms of your energy like
bro just
we have creda
we have protective jealousy of our women
folk
but you're red pill you diute
you're going to read some red pill
scripture by some author that says don't
ever show your woman you're jealous
so your girl comes and she says oh your
wife but you know you might be dating
around if you read through and not
muslim and uh she's gonna say hey i'm
gonna go to the club babe and you're
gonna feel that little your fitrah
what's what's supposed to be functioning
in order it's going to make you jealous
it's going to make you not want to let
her go
you're going to read one of roland
tomasi's books telling you let her go
and you're going to be in your house
crying like a little kid
wondering where she is and why she
hasn't texted you back and essentially
why even go through that situation why
even make yourself not want to seem
insecure stop worrying about what you
should look like or act like to be a man
and just be a man
hmm
i got a couple thoughts bro but uh
i want y'all to go first
and you should go first you know why i
don't want to go first bro
i think what i'm going to say is going
to be very diplomatic and balanced so
i think it'll be a good conclusive uh
thought
before and i think it's actually a
really good point about uh
kind of when you put it all on the women
you take the responsibility away from
the men i think that's very true and
that is definitely what's happening
nowadays um men are not being held
responsible for their women and they're
not taking their role as being a man
very seriously nowadays
and nowadays all the blame
i would say predominantly muslim blame
is being put onto women and that's why
you have branches of red pill that are
just basically anti-women
the second thing i want to say
is that i feel like nowadays with red
pill and how it's being propagated is
failing from the very beginning because
the very beginning predominantly is
always based on this how a lot of red
people get into red pill it's usually in
regards to getting women
now that's already a failure especially
from an islamic perspective because now
you're making the goal just getting
women
yeah and everything that branches off
that comes off of that is also just
going to be a failure it's kind of it's
not going to lead to anything good
yeah
you you kind of say what i was going to
say
in the sense that like if if someone is
operating off this red pill
uh guideline
it only adheres
to hedonistic life
it only adheres to a materialistic life
where it's like when you're following it
again it adheres to that it makes sense
if you live materialistic if you leave
here if you live here in this city it
makes sense okay make as much money as
possible look the best that you can
possibly look
get as many women as you can spend as
many plates as you can don't worry about
getting married don't worry about having
kids don't worry about doing any of this
stuff listen like just
have the women then throw them to the
curb like it makes sense if you are in a
hedonistic lifestyle in a materialistic
lifestyle
but once you transcend that once you
wake up to the reality of like why we
really are here like what the purpose is
and
you you just you can no longer function
off that like
if you tell a muslim
if you tell a muslim right now hey make
as much money as you can
look the best that you can okay
like that that's nice but
if you don't have dark what if you
aren't hitting your prayers if if you
aren't spiritual
what's the point of it all
it's like uh
support
he said it you know
i think the video we all made together
well he was saying that like it's as if
someone's holding up this like dead
animal
and they're enticing me like yo like
look at this like you really want this
right like this right here this is gonna
do it for you and then you think to
yourself man like yo this right here
this bottle
this liquid in this bottle is gonna
solve all my problems i'm gonna feel
good i'm gonna forget all the issues
that i have i'm gonna feel real nice
don't worry this is just water it's not
alcohol
but um
you they they present this bottle to you
and you're like
hmm maybe that bottle is gonna solve all
my issues and then you go into it and
then you realize
once you're too far gone like oh
this was empty
this didn't have the answers that i was
seeking
so again it's like
these uh red pill guidelines it doesn't
work
you know it's like
it's this level and then once you
transcend that you can no longer work at
that level so
i just i pray
and i'm gonna make dua that
the creator
opens the hearts and the ears of people
watching this video who are operating
at that red hill level
so they can transcend and come to the
reality and come to the truth
i've been seeing uh kevin samuels from
like 2000 and i believe 17 or 18 and i
remember like seeing pictures of him
like uh with like louis bags and you
know and it just seems like you're just
chasing this materialistic lifestyle i
feel like a lot of this demographic also
subscribes to rap music and hip-hop
which as a whole just pushes this
narrative that to be successful
you need to live a materialistic life
you need to flaunt these as trophies and
and medals in front of everyone else and
whoever has more
therefore has higher value
and i think that the myth of this high
value man
uh i do believe in high value men but
i'm saying the myth of the high value
man so much as to say that he's equated
to by his money right because that's not
it's not just money that makes you high
value man but this whole thing does come
from subscribing to this
materialistic world bro so i agree with
what both of you are saying
i also understand that kevin samuels and
a lot of these red pill youtube channels
they all have the same trend that
they're coming from a place of hurt
now is there something wrong with that
no because we all have our journeys but
when you keep preaching a message to men
and women but predominantly men
uh about your message about your
personal journey of why you were hurt
and you hyperimpose that into every
single situation it's not gonna work out
but it's not realistic like you can't
help but to come out with uh with this
one way of looking at the world this one
lens there's no black and white there's
no nuances there's no gray
you know what i mean
like
i hear a lot of these uh these black men
they preach about this this black woman
uh that they would you know devote their
love to
give money to give gifts to and then she
did them dirty or she cheated on them
okay like do you like do you think
that's like all women do you think
that's that's gonna be every single
woman that you come across no but what
happens is now you're gonna hyperimpose
that into every single situation and be
like oh all women cheat or all women are
like that
that's dangerous bro that's and i think
that's immature and when you come from
that type of mental point of origin is
is fallible bro because you're operating
with rules from
observations that you've made as a human
being which is subject to error
and you're not using divine guidance
you're not using something infallible
now if you guys watching on our channel
you just found us out you have a problem
with believing in god or you don't even
believe in god check out our episode one
and two and then five
start there but in terms of red pill
the red pill gives you a way of life it
has its truths and it has its lies
and things that they didn't get right
why not subscribe to something that
doesn't have any lies any
inconsistencies it's just perfect it's
just completely pure unadulterated from
the creator and when you vibe with it
you'll know you vibe with it because
it's in you the vibe with it we call it
the fitra
and we're starting a
youtube series or at least an episode
with a youtuber by the name of hamza
who's lived this hedonistic lifestyle
that anaheim was talking about you know
we're not here to air his sins but he's
lived a life where he regrets it and he
he's seen the outcome that it leads to
and he wasn't really on dean and now
he's getting interested into it he wants
to learn more about islam he's going to
come on our channel and we're gonna
we're gonna chop it up but essentially
that's that's all i lead to it just
leads to uh equating your self-worth how
well you do with women
and i think bro as a man there's so much
more but at least as a human being
especially like there's so much more
than just how
sexually appealing you are to the
opposite gender
yeah
bro and
think about it like this
all right let's say we are
on this journey and
at the end
it's the most beautiful thing that
you're ever going to see whatever it is
that you want that to be that's what it
is all right
but somewhere along the line as you're
going through this journey
you stop maybe a quarter of the way
maybe halfway there maybe even 75
of the way you stop and then you say you
know what
i don't need to make it to the end i
think this is perfect just the way it is
even though
you know that the end like it is
completely different
all right that's what red pill is red
pill is
it's it's an awakening because most
dudes who come onto red blue speak for
myself here personally
you're waking up
from this false reality that you were
living prior
right but once you start waking up
it's like
it's like you learn something for the
first time let's say someone's learning
how to dance let's say someone's
learning how to
perform
the
a barbell bench press or a deadlift or
something right you're learning
something when you learn something for
the first time it's an awakening you had
no idea prior and now there's steps in
this awakening there's steps in this
learning process you learn the steps
and then you can start doing this thing
you start to
excel at what you're doing but in order
to truly master what it is that you're
trying to learn you have to stop
thinking about the steps you have to
stop uh being obsessed and only going to
these main steps that you learned in
order to move on to the next thing to
transcend and that's what the red pill
is bro the red pill is like these steps
you're learning the dance moves you're
learning the steps but in order to
really be good at dancing you have to be
able to let go and stop thinking about
the steps so for people on red pill if
y'all are waking up
y'all
just learning the steps that's all right
do what you got to do but understand
that this isn't the end of the journey
the next
step
i'd say even the final step and bro
yeah
all these men have been
weak all their life they've been plugged
into this matrix that
paul paints like this false idea of what
intersexual i guess relations are like
and they finally find the red pill and
they're like yo i've been blue pill all
my life quote unquote and they're like
okay this is like this is something real
this is something that works it works
sometimes but who does it really work on
does it really work on god fearing women
i know bro that was too real for honor
so he just had to step out to get a
quick breath but i'm gonna continue
nonetheless bismillah uh my contention
is this bro and perfect you came back
right when i was gonna start my point
you see red pill and it pretty much in
my opinion right
it's low value solutions for or high
value solutions for low value women
okay what i mean by this is this
you'll find the video how to not get
your girl to cheat on you
you know and it says do all these things
and she'll stay into you and she'll
focus on you it's like bro if she
followed islam
the fact that she would cheat on you
wouldn't even be in the in the equation
does it happen of course i'm not gonna
deny it happens with women and men that
are muslim
but he's a thing isn't the way he
supposed to be if they're god free women
no but it's like you need this
instruction manual to be like okay how
to get her to not cheat on you or how to
get her not to flirt with other men bro
in islam there's no free mixing that's
not even in the equation then you get
what i mean so it's like
it's high-value solutions for low-value
women
or you know vice versa feminism
is is a solution for women
to uh
basically get simps wrapped around their
fingers and it's like both of them deal
with low value people and i think like
if you want to play that game go for it
but understand that that feeling you got
when you first came into red pill from
being you know blue pill all your life
and you finally found something that's
real and you think it's like it's legit
that's the feeling that's that you kind
of have that self-fulfilling prophecy
you have that confirmation bias that's
what we call in psychology so you're
going to continue being subject to
seeing this as the measuring stick of
objective reality
until you begin to realize that okay
maybe maybe i might want to humble
myself and realize okay what if there's
something else out there what if red
pill is not like the final level but
it's like level two and then level three
is objective reality it's divine law and
guidance right it ain't even the truth
either i think about what the red pill
is it's supposed to be the truth but how
can the red bill how can the red pill be
the truth when it's just
everyone who's been on repo every people
who started red pill
they're just kind of trying to figure it
out as they go
you feel me so like they might
understand something now this concept
now
and a few years from now that concept
may change
but like right now in red pill it's said
to not be jealous
don't be jealous over your woman
wait till you actually learn what that
is
the haters
like straight up bro
i don't hate every single red pill
culture hate the whole you know movement
and despise them like i understand where
they're coming from just like i can't
like do i do i think some feminists are
ridiculous of course but do i hate them
like to the point where i think like
there's no saving them no like we need
to understand where they're coming from
a lot of muslim women today are
feminists because their fathers who were
supposed to follow the dean they were
having i guess unequal bias on on women
and their daughters and they created
this weird uh household dynamic where
women were uh
i guess actually oppressed or they were
uh i guess equated to how a man should
be in terms of success like you need to
get that phd you need to do this and
they corrupted their fitra and today
that's what you see
like it does happen both ways so we're
just trying to get you guys to open your
eyes to like
you know the nuances in life and that's
what islam opens your eyes to islam
doesn't say yeah average at best so just
f off like you're never going to get
married just push you to the side of the
curb islam says okay cool if you're
divorced okay like you know it's so
natural divorce your son to marry
version two but it's so it's a sunnah to
me a divorcee or a widow and you should
do that you could do that this is this
is what happens to those women it's not
like they're just gonna be discarded
like trash and they're never gonna get
married you know just because you know
so be it no one wants to marry you it's
a solution
and i think islam is solution oriented
and red pill is a little problem-centric
yeah yeah i just want to add to that you
only need a solution when there's a
problem right yeah islam is more
preventative
islam is the solution all problems but
it's also the the prevention of all
problems before they even come you only
have problems like this and the type of
society that we live in and don't you
guys think it's kind of funny that the
basic ideology of the society we live in
is is based on people going for what
they desire
and with the red pill movement uh the
things that are supposed to get you
women i just happen to be the things
that you desire so it's all just desire
oriented people desire wealth and fame
and status and money right and society
is amplifying that and now with the red
pill movement they're saying if you want
women which is already what you desire
then just go for all the other things
that you already desire and it's like
it's it's so it's so circular that like
it it's going to cause it's going to
cause you to faint one day i don't know
that's how certain it is you're going to
run in this this rat race you know which
is a common phrase uh until you die
essentially listen
mohammed hijab made a uh debate with um
johnny that we you know we uploaded on
channel to get more reach for that and
what i realized was
um
muhammad hijab saying that red pill is
prescriptive he's right
prescriptive meaning it's trying to
become an ideology adeem in a way it's
not complete but it's trying to be and
the proof is in the pudding like you
look around and it's like oh are you
alpha uh no oh then by definition you're
beta are you red pill no okay then your
blue pill oh no or you're an omega or a
delta like bro what does this even mean
like you're so caught up in like
like these little
you know arbitrary uh terminologies to
label yourself as in terms of your
energy like bro just stop worrying about
what you should look like or act like to
be a man and just be a man it's not that
difficult
at least with islam it's not that
difficult
yeah and to what ramen was saying it's
all cyclical
it all continues in this cycle
and like think about it why
why do people feel the need to do all
these things like you said why do we
have these desires like this
like why do we desire to look better why
do we desire to have more money to uh
have power and all this stuff because we
feel inferior
we feel incomplete there's something
inside of us that is looking for that
fulfillment to be complete and so we go
into something and then it's cyclical
right and then let's say you have
someone who's average at best
whether that be a man or a woman
like bro
if they were in islam they would
understand what's actually going on
right like they understand there's a
greater purpose they understand there's
a reason for this right and if someone
is unattractive that is their struggle
that is something that they have to get
past and if if someone is super
attractive that is something that they
have to get past because
you could link it to the same thing if
someone's unattractive you could
link it to having
a scarcity and if someone is attractive
you could link it to having abundance
and we all know that abundance is a
bigger test in scarcity yeah
yeah 100 bro 100 and like you guys don't
have to take advice you do realize that
like all we're trying to do
is
try to be the older brother that we wish
we had essentially you know like you
don't have to take our advice we're
telling you like it's not always about
women now we're not saying the opposite
you know we're not saying it's never
about looks or being with a woman who's
pleasing to your eyes no one's saying
that at all either but imagine having a
girl that you think is a 10
and everything's good the intimacy is
good but
it's not going to be fulfilling at the
end of the day if she's not on
and she doesn't respect you and your
leadership like as a man so at the end
of the day you could have that by all
means you could do it the opposite of
what we're saying you could waste time
and you could sin and you can go even
deeper into your degenerate lifestyle or
you could realize okay nah like there's
these rules for a reason
and if it does corrupted or you don't
know what the hell we're talking about
playlist new to islam start with episode
one
and god willing you were guided to the
truth
yeah
i just want to add one last thing to
that i think that's essentially what
muhammad was saying at the end because
it's not going to fulfill you this this
rat race and it's it's it's circular for
a reason it's never going to fulfill you
and allah i'm paraphrasing a bit but he
says in the quran basically whoever
forgets allah indeed they will have a
depressing life because the way you were
created was with one purpose we all have
the instinct of sanctification to
sanctify or something to worship
something to look up to something out of
respect and and
you know look at the greatness of that
now sometimes most of the time it's it's
one's self their desires what they want
sometimes there's other people looking
up to greatness and others but it's so
rare that you look to the greatness of
allah and you worship him that's what he
was saying at the end because that's
what's going to give you fulfillment you
will never truly be content
until you worship allah and submit to
him alone because that's exactly what
you're created to do and if you think
you're created to go in this rat race
and run around in circles trying to get
money to get women and get women to get
money and
so on and so forth
you're gonna die
a very very very lonely death and that's
the only true form of loneliness when
you're in the grave and the only thing
you have to accompany you is your bad
deeds and the life that you wasted away
hmm
well islam will never be the same as red
pill and red pill will never be the same
as islam
like we have
we have protective jealousy of our women
folk
but you read pill yet diuth
you're gonna read some red pill
scripture by some artist or or some
author that says don't ever show your
woman you're jealous
so your girl comes and she says oh your
wife but you know you might be dating
around if you're read through and not
muslim and uh she's gonna say hey i'm
gonna go to the club babe and you're
gonna feel that little your fitrah
what's what's supposed to be functioning
in order it's gonna make you jealous
it's gonna make you not wanna let her go
you're going to read one of roland
tomasi's books telling you let her go
and you're going to be that red pill uh
i guess noob in your house crying
like a little kid
wondering where she is and why she
hasn't texted you back and essentially
why even go through that situation why
even make yourself not want to seem
insecure just bro like speak your truth
like just be muslim it's simple
yeah
100 well i think that's enough
yeah if y'all made it this far go ahead
and hashtag
hashtag
hijab10
yeah me a lot grant all of you guys
uh a wonderful and blessed life
in this dunya and in the hereafter
and give you
for your woman folk and for the dem
and uh
that's all i gotta say smash that like
button
do you think bro
with that being said
i think there's another thing too it's
it's the perseverance aspect too like
we're more willing to stick through with
things that we set out with an intention
it's impossible to have empathy for
others if you're not patient so my love
bless you for that first of all i agree
with the fact that
the whole thing you said about friends
where it's like if they're affecting you
more than you're affecting them then you
should probably get some new friends
you want to be investing
stocks shares bonds you want to be
investing in crypto
because there's this thing called
inflation which means every year that
passes by
the value of a dollar goes lower and
lower and lower and the reason being is
because they're printing more money
right that's why money is haram at least
the paper money is haram provided that
you're actually there and you're being a
good father and the mother's being a
good mother best conditions and behind
the mic hamza andreas zorces we will go
in with our final three with brother
angel inshallah
it's not just a responsibility on you
it's responsibility on all the children
especially your father in our private
area is very elastic and yeah if you go
too fast the skin will literally crease
up into like the edge
of like the little clipper things and
you will literally clip your skin you
don't want to be on youtube or the
internet or anything
that that amount of time but it's it's
the the fact is that's what we're doing
um
[Music]
[Music]
hmm